salut à tous c'est christophe pour la
chronique politique quand on veut
contester le bien fondé d'une idéologie
ou d'un concept on a plusieurs solutions
on peut d'abord affirmé des valeurs
opposées en produisant un
contre-discours on peut également essayé
de démonter la théorie de l'intérieur en
montrant par exemple ses faiblesses ses
contradictions internes ou bien ces
points aveugles
on peut aussi à confronter avec la
réalité est aujourd'hui je voulais vous
parler des théories néo féministes ou
féministes postmoderne ces théories sont
arrivés discrètement il y a une grosse
dizaine d'années en france avant de
devenir hégémonique mais existent dans
le monde anglo saxon depuis une
trentaine d'années dans ce pays qui ne
sont donc pas uniquement des théories
pure mais ils ont aussi donné lieu à des
pratiques qui ont transformé les façons
de faire du nom de militants mais aussi
en raison des impacts dans le monde
social
elles ont modifié le fonctionnement
d'institutions et elles ont contribué à
l'élaboration de certaines lois allant
dans leur sens on peut donc confronté
cette théorie à la réalité et voir si
conformément à leurs discours elles ont
réussi à aider les femmes à s'émanciper
et aujourd'hui je vais donc essayer de
faire un bilan de cette théorie en axant
en particulier sur un sou courant qui
est le cours entre ans féministe
outrance activistes qui est donc axée
autour de la question des transsexuels
je vais faire cela parce que ce courant
aux dires à des féministes critique et
bien est en train de facto citer toutes
les questions féministes
allez c'est parti tout d'abord il faut
bien comprendre que pour les féministes
post moderne
la séparation entre hommes et femmes est
binaire et oppressive et à désolé on me
fait signe que robert a et nathalie par
leur physique avantageux véhicules et
des critères de beauté oppressif
bon et bien au revoir robert et nathalie
et bonjour à saddam et margaret des gens
beaucoup moins agressif mais un petit
peu oppressant bref revenons à nos
moutons pour les idées postmoderne la
séparation entre hommes et femmes est
binaire et oppressive et de + 7 bis
catégorisation pour reprendre un de leur
terme serait une pure construction
sociale donc pour libérer les hommes et
les femmes ou plus
les individus il faut faire éclater ces
catégories en niant toute base
biologique au sexe d'où la
multiplication des genres intercalaires
gender fluides non binaire ou encore les
trans qui représente la transgression
ultime de ces genres biologique honni on
parle de transe mtu f pour les hommes
devenant des femmes et 2f tôt m
pour les femmes devenant des hommes
cette transformation d'ailleurs n'est
pas forcément physiques et peut être
purement administrative
on peut avoir physiquement le corps d'un
homme et se considérer comme une femme
et surtout être reconnus par la société
et les institutions comme tel et la
l'absurde commence dans certains sports
les trans peuvent concourir dans des
disciplines dans la catégorie de leur
sexe d'adoption c'est un phénomène qu'on
voit de plus en plus ces sportifs sont
surtout des mtf puisque leur musculature
masculine leur donne souvent un avantage
non négligeable sur leurs concurrentes
par exemple en 2018 c'est un transsexuel
rachel mackinnon qui a gagné les
championnats du monde féminin de
cyclisme sur piste à ses détracteurs
cette championne a rétorqué que les
vraies sportives voyait d'un bon oeil ce
type de concurrence et de challenge
effectivement pour une femme battre
quelqu'un qui a la masse musculaire d'un
homme de bon gabarit est bel et bien un
challenge
autre exemple qui a défrayé la chronique
en drague à lire ou d' un jeune afro
américains qui depuis 2010 est alors
qu'ils n'avaient pas entamé de
traitement hormonal concours dans des
championnats d'athlétisme féminin
parfois ils gagnent contre des femmes
alors que ces résultats ne lui
permettrait pas d'être qualifiés en
championnat masculin
ces championnats aux usa peuvent ouvrir
des portes universitaire et dans ses
affaires il n'est donc pas uniquement
question de beauté du sport
alors tout cela peut paraître un petit
peu anecdotique mais cette théorie
postmoderne en abolissant la frontière
biologique entre hommes et femmes dans
certains pays ouvre l'accès à certains
endroits avons réservé aux femmes à des
hommes par exemple un homme qui se dit
femmes pourraient être accueillis au
sein d'un refuge pour femmes battues ou
bien sans abri ou encore un violeur une
fois condamné pourrait se dire femmes et
ainsi être transférée dans une prison
pour femmes
dans les deux cas on pourrait avoir un
prédateur sexuel qui serait au milieu de
ses proies précaires voire captive
alors vous allez vous dire que ce genre
d'idées est un délire de gros réac et
bien détrompez vous car ce genre
d'affaires a déjà eu lieu au canada
christopher and brooke a été hébergé
dans des refuges pour femmes sdf
oui la grèce
sexuellement deux d'entre elles pourtant
ce type avait un casier judiciaire
chargé qui avait de quoi inquiéter
il avait déjà violé une fillette de 5
ans et à peine sorti de prison avait
violé une jeune femme handicapée
mais voilà depuis ses affaires il disait
se sentir femme et se faisait appeler
jessica ce qui lui a ouvert les portes
de ces refuges
quant à la sphère de la prison pour
femmes les faits se sont déroulés au
royaume uni stephen wood un agresseur
sexuel récidiviste qui avait violé un
adolescent de 12 ans une femme enceinte
et tenté de tuer un voisin en le
poignardant à entamer une transition de
genre une fois en prison est sous le nom
de karine white a été transférée dans
une prison pour femmes où il a agressé
sexuellement plusieurs de ses co détenus
malgré son passé criminel il a pu être
envoyé dans une prison pour femmes grâce
aux gender recognition act une loi votée
en 2004 permettant aux transsexuels
d'accéder aux lieux réservés aux
personnes de leur sexe choisi selon la
bbc en 2018 en grande bretagne il y
avait 125 transgenres en prison 60
d'entre eux étaient incarcérés pour des
affaires liées à des délits ou crimes
sexuels inutile de vous dire que leurs
codétenus doivent se sentir en sécurité
théorie aberrante qui mènent donc à des
situations aberrantes et pourtant peu de
personnes dans les milieux militants
s'interrogent sur les conséquences
réelles des idées qu'elle propage
les seuls qui combattent ces idées sont
celles qu'on appelle les féministes
radicales ou gender critique et ce n'est
pas ensuite sans conséquence sur leur
capacité à militer et à s'exprimer dans
ces milieux souvent lesbienne est un peu
mise en dhr anti-prostitution
antipornographie vus comme des
exploitations du corps des femmes elles
sont attachées à la définition
biologique des sexes et considèrent les
transsexuels comme des hommes venant
phagocyter leur espace et leur lutte ils
reproduisent en une forme de domination
masculine qui ne dit pas son nom à cause
de leurs critiques les féministes
radicales sont perçus comme des ennemis
par les féministes postmoderne et trans
activistes qui les ont affublé du terme
péjoratif de tlf
pour féministes radicales excluant les
trans ce terme d'un point de vue
symbolique et qui vous un peu à être
étiqueté fachos chez les féministes et à
se voir exclues du sacro-saint camp
progressiste
par exemple julie avec une féministe
radicale de baltimore lesbiennes a été
exclu d'une commission municipale lgbt
pour y avoir évoqué le cas de karine
white et s'est mis tout ce petit monde
progressiste à dos depuis elle a
effectué un renversement d'alliance
donnant une conférence à la fondation
héritage un think tank libéral
conservateur ou encore une interview à
fox news
les théories postmoderne
par leur intolérance pousse dans les
bras de leurs ennemis celles et ceux qui
de gauche n'y adhèrent pas en france une
féministe radicale aussi a fait les
frais de l'utilisation de sa liberté
d'expression en janvier 2020 marguerite
stern une ancienne femen inventrice
décollage féministe a eu le malheur de
critiquer sur twitter la présence de
plus en plus visible et transgenres dans
le mouvement féministe le détournant de
son sujet initial les femmes au profit
exclusif de la question trans cette
série de tweets a fait scandale dans le
landerneau progressistes dans la foulée
un texte la soutenant avait été publiée
sur le site du huffington post
mais devant la levée de boucliers et les
cris d'orfraie des féministes
postmoderne
la tribune a été retirée du site depuis
marguerite stern a été blacklisté et
continue son activité dans son coin
cette négation du corps comme base de
définition de l'individu fait que même
les questions et aux corps des femmes
pourtant base de lutte historique passe
de plus en plus à la trappe car vu comme
oppressive par les trans féministe doha
moutot par exemple une féministe
française s'est ainsi fait prendre à
partie et a subi une campagne de
harcèlement sur les réseaux sociaux
parce qu'un activiste trans trouvait
anormal qu'elle parle de clitoris toutes
les femmes post moderne n'en ayant pas
certaines ayant un pénis l'activiste
trans d'ailleurs promu par le service
public a vu dans cette campagne
motif à s'indigner le corps féminin
naturel est oppressif pour ces corps
artificialisés transformer à coups de
bistouri dans le même genre à l'ami 2020
c'est jk rowling l'auteur de harry
potter qui a fait les frais de sa
liberté de parole après avoir osé
rappeler que les femmes ont un utérus
elle a été la cible d'une campagne de
harcèlement visant à la cancel et à la
faire taire
étrange activistes déployant à cette
occasion une agressivité toute masculine
d'ailleurs jk rowling a été soutenue en
france par un texte signé par des
féministes non post moderne dont
marguerite stern texte publié dans le
figaro
on voit là peut-être les premiers signes
en france d'un retournement d'alliance
d'une partie du féminisme comme ça a été
le cas pour julia bec aux usa et pour
finir je vais vous raconter une anecdote
qui m'est arrivé dans mon parcours
militant il y à une demi douzaine
d'années je militais encore à l'extrême
gauche au sein d'un syndicat étudiant
d'extrême gauche
donc non pas l'unef et une année il
avait été proposé de faire une campagne
contre la transphobie notre syndicat
local qui était très axé sur la question
des classes etc
avait argué que il fallait peut-être
mieux faire une campagne qui toucherait
plus de personnes par exemple la
question des bourses étudiantes ou du
logement
et bien cette prise de position a été
interprétée par l'immense majorité du
syndicat comme étant transphobes et au
niveau national des gens ont voulu faire
une commission d' enquête sur nous pour
savoir si on était d'horribles
transphobes et ont voulu nous éjecter du
syndicat tout ça parce que nous n'avions
pas voté pour la campagne sur la
transphobie qu'ils avaient proposé pour
ces gens déjà il ya une demi douzaine
d'années ne pas être 100% d'accord avec
eux ne pas vouloir une campagne
d'affichage s'était déjà être
transphobes et être dans le camp de
l'ennemi
c'est dire à quel point ces gens une
définition totalement biaisée de la
démocratie en tout cas voilà donc ce que
d'hommes ces théories néo féministe et
30 activistes une fois transposée dans
le réel
de par leur volonté non pas d'émanciper
et de libérer les femmes mais de
dissoudre les catégories hommes et
femmes pour tenir non pas des hommes et
des femmes libres et des individus
libres et détachée de toute notion de
genre et de sexe physique et bien elle
dit soldes des catégories qui en fin de
compte permettait de protéger les femmes
par des lois spécifiques ou des lieux
d'accueil spécifique
ces théories en fin de compte n'aide pas
les femmes est au contraire les met
potentiellement en danger
et cette vidéo est maintenant terminée
s'il vous a intéressé
n'hésitez pas à la partager et à vous
abonner ça aide à la visibilité de la
chaîne et sur ce il ne me reste plus
qu'à vous dire à la prochaine